hoje
[Música]
em 2013 e eu falei é com essa frase que
eu queria começar a nossa conversa de
hoje porque não tem nada mais frustrante
nada pior do que você tem que conhecer
os seus próprios erros falhas e muitas
vezes tem meus dias mais do que isso
você conhecer e ter que lidar com todas
as adversidades do mundo que a gente
vive hoje eu falei eu tava mergulhado
dos meus problemas não encontrava
nenhuma solução
trabalhando noites e noite virando
noites inclusive mas o pior de tudo eu
não enxergava a luz no fim do túnel
e além de tudo isso eu tava pesando mais
de 100 quilos na balança com esses
glicêmicos altíssimos
sem poder ter tempo e dedicação para o
meu próprio corpo e organismo quando um
amigo meu me convidou para correr os
meus primeiros 10km
e eu vou te avisar os meus saudáveis 75
kg
mente e corpo se alinharam e a resolução
dos diversos problemas que eu tinha
começaram a surgir a minha empresa que
estava praticamente falida muda as
estratégias de abordagem e começa a
atuar em outras frentes de trabalho em
Junho deste ano a minha empresa do setor
de eventos um setor que foi altamente
impactado com a realidade que a gente
vive
completou 9 anos com muitos desafios
aliás novos desafios pela frente qual
foi o grande momento os seus momentos
mais importante de toda essa história
que eu contei para você
e o respiro o respiro foi o grande ter
Point que me deu subsídios para poder
enfrentar todos aqueles problemas que eu
tava vivendo afinal de contas eu sou
empresário um eterno aprendiz do mundo
dos negócios da vida e das pessoas eu
sou filho do Rui e da Marcha tammura só
um amigo fiel namorado incrível Ou pelo
menos Essas são as características que
eu em qualquer pessoa no mundo gostaria
de almejar na sua vida você já ouviu
falar das famosas salas de compressão ou
daqueles ambientes Descolados que
empresas como Google Facebook o Horto
proporcionam para os seus colaboradores
ou condomínios esses espaços nascem do
modelo denominado Taylor smo ou
organização científica do trabalho que
consiste no aumento da produtividade
através da economia e do controle do
tempo empregado no trabalho e também nas
atividades sociais Segundo a OMS o de
18. 6 milhões de brasileiros ou seja
quase nove porcento da população sofre
de algum problema relacionado a
ansiedade sem a correta identificação ou
tratamento pode desencadear uma série de
outros comportamentos depressivos que
vão consequentemente afetar os
relacionamentos e interações sociais
Lembrando que a interação social
elemento fundamental da Inteligência
Emocional isso mesmo a inteligência
emocional é aquela responsável pela
forma com que você acha nos momentos
mais difíceis da sua vida mas para ver a
interação social a vimos aqui um leque
de várias outras frentes na nossa vida
que precisam ser cuidadas carinhosamente
mente corpo alma e família e determinado
momento da minha vida profissional eu me
vi travado nada andava e buscava
resoluções os meus problemas e enfim
resolvi nesse momento retomar as minhas
terapias e o foco da minha terapia era
trabalho
e quando o de repente a minha terapeuta
olhou para mim disse enquanto você não
tratar e solucionar os problemas
pessoais que você tem com seu pai nem o
trabalho e nem a vida pessoal vamos
caminhar
e o problema pessoal que a minha
terapeuta tal se referindo era o fato de
eu não confirme assumir homossexual com
meu pai só quem já passou por isso sabe
que é de fato um grande desafio quando a
gente fala de se assumir nós não estamos
falando simplesmente
enxergar essas pessoas externalizar
aquela ideia eu tô falando de
desconstruir todo uma imagem criada por
mim pelas pessoas pelos meus pais de mim
mesmo
e aí Olha você só consegue falar o
esterilizar isso para as pessoas quando
você Vence a primeira etapa você mesmo
quando eu me convenci que eu realmente
precisava externalizar aquilo que o meu
pai todos os meus problemas se tornaram
tão pequenos perto daquele Grande
Desafio que eu ainda tinha pela frente e
pasmo eu consegui não foi exatamente do
jeito que eu imaginei nem tão ruim
quando eu pensei
incrivelmente após esse episódio até os
meus negócios foram Talvez isso tenha me
dado musculatura que eu poder enfrentar
todos os desafios que eu tinha aquela
frente fizeram com que aqueles problemas
profissionais se tornassem algo muito
pequeno naquele Universo de coisas que
eu tinha para resolver você aí de casa
tendo enfrentado o mesmo problema que eu
ou não já se viu com problemas pessoais
que estavam te bloqueando em outras
frentes da sua vida ou já teve seu corpo
pedindo por ajuda e quando você atendeu
seu dia rendeu mais Ou aquele momento
que você está mergulhado em uma série de
problemas que quando você Desencana de
repente e as soluções mais simples
surgem na sua mente lembra daquele
menino que eu era lá em 2013 quando eu
olho para trás eu vejo que eu
enfrentaria tudo de novo foi a minha
trajetória que me deu musculatura e
conhecimento para eu entender o mundo Ou
melhor o meu mundo como ele é hoje
muitas vezes o problema está justamente
no fato da gente não querer enfrentar
aqueles problemas que a gente julga não
ser o grande foco do momento parar
respirar e sair do olho do furacão faz
parte de todo o processo
um olhar por outros prismas da vida
conhecer outras realidades tudo isso faz
parte de um único universo o seu cuide
dele